we bought our house 15 years ago it's
170ish years old W and my biggest
argument is stop watching HGTV before
you buy a house because it was the
stupidest thing we've ever done my
husband has always always wanted to
build a sizable Workshop um he has
Hobbies other big heavy machinery and
he's slightly hoard hoarder plan always
was build a workshop then we would have
the re the space to solve other house
problems I have been here long enough to
know that my house needs too much like
our foundation massive issues like you
know everything is old nothing is
everything's basically going to need
replaced at some point here's the deal
there's not a right or wrong here you
have just Twisted yourself up like a
pretzel you talked about the anxiety
thing my $1,500 a month mortgage doesn't
give me anxiety anymore a new house
another $1,000 a month mortgage on top
of that does